Sometimes, the SCP Foundation needs to get
creative with how they go about securing,
containing, and protecting.
Sadly not everything can be solved with a
Mobile Task Force, or by locking it away securely
in a concrete chamber.
Which brings us to SCP-2480, otherwise known
by the nickname “An Unfinished Ritual.”
When initially looking through the file on
SCP-2480, the reader will immediately notice
a number of discrepancies throughout.
Parts of the entry have been crossed out.
They’ve been struck through so they are
still readable, not redacted completely for
the purposes of secrecy like many of the details
in other SCP files.
First and foremost, SCP-2480 has been reclassified
multiple times, first as “Safe”, then
changed to the infamous “Keter” class.
But now, it is listed as the far more ominous
“Presumed Neutralized.”
It’s disconcerting, because “presumed”
definitely leaves a lot of questions.
So, what exactly is SCP-2480?
SCP-2480 is an area of dimensional abnormality,
apparently created when an occult ritual was
interrupted in November of 1952, hence the
nickname of “An Unfinished Ritual.”
The source of this anomaly is located in a
heavily forested town somewhere near the coast
of Massachusetts.
Of course, this state has long been synonymous
with many occult happenings, Massachusetts
famously being home to a number of supposedly
haunted houses and sites of supernatural activity.
And SCP-2480 is no exception, seeming to fit
both of those criteria.
In order to keep an eye on SCP-2480, the Foundation
has dispatched Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6,
also codenamed the “Village Idiots.”
These operatives are working undercover in
the surrounding area and nearby town, keeping
watch for any sightings of anomalous activity.
Meanwhile, another team, MTF Psi-9 the “Abyss
Gazers”, are stationed nearby, in case any
incidents should arise.
These operatives have been authorized by the
SCP Foundation to employ the use of lethal
force on any and all anomalous manifestations
they should encounter.
Their directive is to destroy without prejudice.
That sure sounds like a lot of effort to secure
something classed as “Presumed Neutralized”.
The anomaly itself is centered around an old
Massachusetts house, known as Bodfel Manor.
The manor was once the home of a millionaire
industrialist by the name of Cornelius P.
Bodfel III, who died in 1952 at the age of
eighty-six.
And yes, he died in the same year that the
ritual that created SCP-2480 took place.
But we’re sure that’s probably just a
coincidence, right?
Interestingly, during his life, Cornelius
Bodfel apparently had something of a fascination
with the occult.
It was likely this interest that drew him
to creating a supernatural cult known as Adytum’s
Wake.
Little is known about this organization and
Adytum’s Wake are not part of the SCP Foundation’s
Groups of Interest, the list of other anomalous
groups that often rival the Foundation.
Much like the anomaly itself, they’re presumed
neutralized.
The Foundation conducted a full scale investigation
into Bodfel Manor, and were able to unearth
more information about the aforementioned
cult.
Fortunately, Cornelius Bodfel kept a series
of meticulous and detailed journals, as well
as photographs that give plenty of insight
into the activities of Adytum’s Wake.
Unfortunately, a lot of what they got up to
wasn’t all that pleasant.
But what did you expect from a group of cultists?
Adytum’s Wake would engage in all kinds
of depraved behavior, some that’s better
left to the imagination.
What we can say is they’d often perform
ritualistic human sacrifice and indulge in
cannibalism, and these are some of their less
unpleasant crimes.
On site personnel also uncovered sermon notes
in Bodfel’s journals, detailing the cult’s
services and occult practices.
They also found lists of the Adytum’s Wake
members, including local wealthy families
and respected politicians, other industrialists
like Cornelius Bodfel, and even priests and
other religious figures.
The Foundation had previously been aware of
Adytum’s Wake, but initially dismissed the
group as little more than a “decadent upper-class
social club” not worthy of a full investigation.
Let’s review, shall we?
We have a dimensional anomaly in a Massachusetts
manor, a cult obsessed with the supernatural,
and some sort of ritual that occurred in November,
1952, but was interrupted before its completion.
All parts of the same bizarre and twisted
puzzle, but there’s still a piece yet to
be uncovered.
That missing piece?
The Global Occult Coalition.
Who would have expected the GOC to rear their
ugly heads around here?
Though it’s worth mentioning that many of
the GOC’s member groups are occult in nature,
so it probably shouldn’t come as that much
of a surprise that they were somehow involved
in this case, too..
It goes without saying that the SCP Foundation
shares a complicated relationship with this
particular Group of Interest, each often disagreeing
with the other’s methods.
Occasionally, the GOC and SCP Foundation will
put aside their differences and act as allies
against large scale threats like The Scarlet
King, but any alliance between them is often
uneasy and short lived.
In the case of SCP-2480, The Foundation were
first alerted to the anomaly’s existence
when they decoded a GOC distress signal, tracing
its source to Bodfel Manor.
When the investigative team arrived, they
found deceased bodies littered throughout
the estate, thirty six corpses in total.
Eight of these were confirmed to be Coalition
operatives and the rest were theorized to
be dead members of Adytum’s Wake.
Almost all of the corpses found at Bodfel
Manor displayed signs of anomalous causes
of death - some had imploded, some disintegrated,
and others had their bodies twisted into fatal
new shapes.
At first glance, and given the GOC’s mission
to destroy the supernatural, it looked as
if they had stormed in and interrupted the
Adytum’s Wake cult while they were right
in the middle of performing a ritual.
Things went awry, SCP-2480 was created, and
caused everyone nearby to die horrifically.
Surely that’s the whole story, right?
Well, not quite, as it turns out.
While there were no surviving GOC operatives
for the Foundation to interrogate, the investigative
team were able to uncover documents related
to the operation in a nearby safehouse used
by the GOC.
Much of the official documentation was destroyed
in an attempted coverup, but a torn remainder
of a mission report was recovered in the safehouse’s
fireplace.
It was actually the Global Occult Coalition
who had initiated the ritual, though its true
purpose was lost.
The Foundation had learned that the SCP-2480
area had been inadvertently created by the
GOC and their heavy-handed approach to their
mission.
But why would an anti-occult organization
attempt a supernatural ritual?
Theories as to their intention seem to point
to the penultimate piece of the puzzle: Sarkicism,
a widespread religious cult that worships
flesh and disease.
The very existence of this religion is viewed
as a threat of apocalyptic proportions by
the SCP Foundation.
Sarkicism was initially founded by the Grand
Karcist Ion, but it has since split into a
number of smaller sub-groups over the millennia.
And among those groups?
Adytum’s Wake.
The GOC mission report fragment gathered by
the Foundation describes the operatives’
target to be Grand Karcist Ion himself.
He apparently cannot be directly perceived,
so few actual descriptions of his form exist.
It has been noted, by some, to be humanoid
in appearance at least, wearing what looks
to be vestments similar to a priest’s and
carrying a staff.
Ion is able to disappear and reappear at will,
and possesses a plethora of reality-altering
capabilities.
The Sarkic founder is able to shift and reshape
any organic material, as well as having the
ability to bend the very fabric of reality
around him.
While he may hold a humanoid shape, this entity
is certainly not human, at least not any longer.
Functionally immortal, Grand Karcist Ion is
noted to frequently exhibit signs of malignant
narcissism and megalomania.
So, now the story shifts: The GOC was attempting
to use Adytum’s Wake to summon Ion in order
for them to eradicate the leader of the Sarkic
religion.
The plan backfired though, SCP-2480 was summoned,
and both the cult and Coalition operatives
were killed.
End of story, right?
Except there is one more twist in this tale
of cults and secrets.
And that twist came from the last place anyone
would expect…
It came from inside the SCP Foundation.
After SCP-2480 was created by the ritual at
Bodfel Manor, Site 13 was established in order
to keep the anomalous area contained.
You see, if the ritual was an atomic blast,
then SCP-2480 was both the crater and the
nuclear fallout from that blast.
Except instead of causing radiation sickness,
the entire area around Bodfel Manor became
dimensionally unstable and prone to anomalous
occurrences.
Overseeing Site 13 was Director Simon Oswalt,
a Foundation bureaucrat.
Simon had been selected for this duty thanks
to his distinct lack of imagination, and because
the anomalous area of SCP-2480 was thought
to be inconsequential at the time.
In 1988, Oswalt failed to deliver his regular
report on SCP-2480’s activity.
This was initially thought to be a simple
error, except the Foundation couldn’t get
in contact with Site 13.
Why?
Because the Unfinished Ritual hadn’t actually
failed.
It wasn’t unfinished, the GOC had succeeded
in summoning Grand Karcist Ion.
And Simon Oswalt had been the one to discover
this.
The founder of Sarkicism appeared to Oswalt,
who was converted and turned against his superiors
at the SCP Foundation.
Ion was able to exert his influence over the
former bureaucrat, swaying him to change sides
by showing Oswalt a description in the Foundation’s
personnel dossier on him that referred to
him as a “mirthless dullard.”
Turning his back on the Foundation and pledging
himself to Sarkicism, Simon Oswalt was granted
anomalous abilities by Grand Karcist Ion.
Oswalt was given the power to control an army
of anomalous entities called Sarkites that
he could summon through the area of SCP-2480.
Grand Karcist Ion dubbed Simon with a new
name, Karcist Karvas, and made him the leader
of his new army.
Their goal was to bring about the Sarkic religion’s
ideal, the dawn of a new age of flesh that
would spell destruction for humanity.
When the Foundation lost contact with Site
13, they dispatched two agents to investigate,
Samuel Roe and Sarah Valentine.
Unaware of Oswalt’s conversion to Sarkicism
and his new purpose as Karcist Karvas, both
agents were captured by the Sarkite creatures
within SCP-2480.
The same monsters were also terrorizing the
nearby town, replacing citizens and sometimes
even kidnapping and devouring them.
Another team was later sent in to survey the
area, only to be killed or replaced as well,
with only one survivor: Doctor Calixto Narváez.
Narváez reported on the situation to the
O5 Council, and in collaboration with the
Global Occult Coalition, the Foundation launched
an assault against Oswalt.
The joint task force of the two organizations
were able to neutralize the Sarkites, reclaiming
the area of SCP-2480 and capturing Simon Oswalt.
Without his control, the creatures became
directionless, unable to so much as eat or
defend themselves.
Grand Karcist Ion’s plan had been thwarted,
and Oswalt was taken back to an SCP Foundation
Site, though now under a new name: SCP-2480-1.
However, during an operation at Containment
Area 14, Oswalt seemed to suffer no effects
from anaesthetic or surgical incision.
Foundation researchers were horrified to learn
that Oswalt no longer possessed any internal
organs, save for his brain, heart, and lungs.
The rest of him was empty.
Later, he was interrogated and began raving
about Grand Karcist Ion, so much that the
doctor questioning Oswalt attempted to attack
him.
Breaking free of his restraints, Simon Oswalt
amputated both of the doctor’s arms before
he was re-contained by guards.
Since then, the area of SCP-2480 has been
mostly quiet, but it still remains under the
Foundation’s close watch just in case any
anomalous happenings start up again.
But if you’re planning a tour of the many
haunted old houses of Massachusetts, we’d
recommend maybe avoiding Bodfel Manor, just
to be safe.
Now go check out “SCP-1730 - What Happened
to Site-13?” and “SCP-4999 - Someone to
Watch Over Us Tale” for more supernatural
tales from the SCP Foundation!